[Music]
fever
then swollen lymph nodes
and then large lesions forming all over
your body
after more than two years of covet 19
the next pandemic might be spreading
around the world
and you could be one of the first people
to contract it
what would happen to your body if you
got monkey box
how could you get it without even
leaving your country
and what are the chances we could be on
the verge of the next viral outbreak
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you got monkey pox
[Music]
monkey pox is the next virus everyone is
talking about and just like covet 19
it's zoonotic meaning it can be
transmitted to you from an infected
animal
it's similar to smallpox but it isn't
quite that
unlike covet 19 monkey pox has been
around for decades
since the 1970s it's been reported in
central and west africa
and just recently the virus made it into
the western world
one thing that really worries scientists
now is that you don't even have to go to
africa to get infected
you see the world has dealt with monkey
pox cases before
some of those infected may have brought
it from nigeria which has been dealing
with a large outbreak since 2017
but this time
it's different
it looks like it could be spread to you
by getting intimate with someone
although health authorities aren't sure
how people are catching monkey pox
outside of central and west africa there
is one interesting theory
it suggests that you could get infected
during sexual intercourse
well before you get excited science is
still unclear if you could get monkey
pox specifically through sexual
transmission but you could get it
through bodily fluids lesions or
respiratory droplets of someone who's
already infected
[Music]
what scientists do know for sure is that
you can contract monkey pox if you come
into contact with an infected animal's
body fluids
and before you start being alert around
monkeys
these primates don't have much to do
with spreading the virus
monkey pox is typically carried by small
rodents like tree squirrels rope
squirrels and dorm ice
if you were carrying the virus
you wouldn't know right away
that's because monkey pox has an
incubation period between 5 and 21 days
when the infection kicked in the first
thing you'd notice would be a fever
you'd have a horrible headache and you'd
feel very tired
these symptoms could last for up to five
days
at first it wouldn't really be much
different from chickenpox or measles
except your lymph nodes would get
swollen so watch them closely
after one to three days of fever things
would start getting worse
you'd experience a rash all over your
face hands and feet
there's a 70 chance you'd get an
eruption inside your mouth and a 30
chance the rash would spread to your
genitalia
it could even affect your eyes
you could get lucky and only have a few
lesions or you could have several
thousand of them
[Music]
first they'd look like slightly raised
bumps on your skin
then they'd get filled with clear fluid
in one or two days this fluid would get
yellowish and about a week after that
your lesions would dry up and fall off
not too bad right
well unfortunately it could get worse
it's possible that monkey pox wouldn't
be the only virus attacking your body
it could come with potentially serious
secondary issues like pneumonia
encephalitis and infection of the
corneas
and there's not one approved treatment
for monkey pox
smallpox antivirals can help you treat
monkey pox but you could manage your
symptoms by drinking lots of fluids and
eating well
you should also make sure that you're
vaccinated against smallpox
scientists confirmed that the smallpox
vaccine is about 85 percent effective at
preventing monkeybox
other than that you'd likely be fine
after a couple of weeks
only some scars on your skin would
remain as a reminder that you'd
contracted monkey pox
now overall there's no reason to panic
and stock up on toilet paper monkey pox
is no covet 19. it can't be transmitted
across a room
plus monkey pox is nothing new
we weren't prepared to face covet 19 but
we have decades of information on the
monkey pox virus and a working vaccine
so
let's not lose our heads over it
unless we decided to stop all
vaccinations altogether
but
that's a story
for another
what if
one more thing
special thanks again to nucleus medical
media for providing these incredible 3d
animations
if you want to watch more scientifically
accurate medical visuals check out their
channel linked in the description below